hi there Steve Kaufman yeah it's going
alright last video I said that I had
felt that I had sort of failed in my
efforts to learn Croatian again I'm not
sure where I'm supposed to look here I
got the Sun in my eyes but I want to go
back I want to take that back I don't
think there is failure in language
learning there is just the need to
continue what you're doing the need for
more time by the way I'm sitting on our
little balcony here in Ole Miss you can
hear people eating lunch down in the
courtyard it's a lovely little town here
you know apparently it was the home of
pirates and but it was a great place for
us to use as a base from here we went
north to Zadar south as far as Dubrovnik
into Sarajevo in Bosnia and had an
absolutely spectacular visit to Croatia
and Bosnia I heartily recommend both
places we didn't get to Montenegro or
Serbia but that's for next time
now I said in the previous video that I
had worked hard for ten days on our mini
stories that link to bring my
serbo-croatian up to a level where I had
hoped that I might be able to
communicate with people here in Croatia
and I said that I failed I failed
because on the one hand I just couldn't
find the words when I tried to speak and
second of all because people in Croatia
at least in the tourist areas all speak
English very very well so that was
they've just weren't gonna humor me
there they work in a restaurant they
work in a store they have work to do
they're not gonna they're not my
language tutor and so I said I kind of
failed there but I want to take that
back
because actually I realized and it's a
good experience for me I realized that
in language learning there is no failure
there is insufficient time language
learning takes time it takes time for
the brain to get used to a new language
even for a related a language that's
related to one that you know I had that
experience in trying to learn Portuguese
even though I already knew Spanish and
French
it takes time this is a process of
getting used to the language it's not a
process of deliberately trying to learn
something and this getting used to takes
time it takes exposure listening reading
speaking and I simply haven't had enough
time with Croatian however since the
last time we spoke a number of things
have happened
first of all while in Croatia I haven't
been able to spend as much time with my
many stories and with my work on link
which in a way is a good thing because
you know that period of benign neglect I
found that having left it for a few days
when I went back to the same material
it was fresher I was noticing things
that I hadn't that I had I thought I had
noticed and learned but I had forgotten
the second thing was up in Sarajevo
there were quite a few people who didn't
speak English also going into Dubrovnik
which is a spectacular sight we had a
taxi driver an uber driver from mostar
in bosnia and he didn't speak english
and i was communicating with with these
people quite well we were also in a in a
shop on our way back from core tula and
the lady there didn't speak English and
my wife was buying something and I was
able to explain and have a little
chitchat all in Serb or Croat Croatian
whatever and of course there's always
these words that are missing but finding
more and more of them and then when I go
back to working with my many stories I
know this thing especially the key was
like when why because that I know and
yet when I need them in a discussion I
can't find them and I'll see them again
and it reinforces itself and so I find
that I am starting to get used to the
language mmm in other words there is no
failure whatever I have put into the
language it's there it might fade a bit
I might forget some things but I can
always go back to it it's like having
blazed the trail through the snow with
your cross-country skiing and if you
pass by a couple of hours later
and has been snowing the tracks will be
sort of covered but it won't be as hard
as the first time and very quickly you
start gliding and picking up speed
so there is no failure there's just the
need to have patience and to be a little
bit realistic it does take time but but
the brain will even you know not having
looked at the Croatian when I go back to
it again and rediscover those words it's
kind of reinforced so I guess I want to
just end off we're going tomorrow to
Spain a with with the sense that I'm
very happy with the effort that I put
into serbo-croatian Croatian not only do
I find that I'm more and more able to
communicate on link I bring in newspaper
articles this is from Serbian newspapers
I can read them I'm looking upwards but
then it's not difficult it's not
difficult a lot of words there that I
know from other Slavic languages or that
I've already learned in serbo-croatian
so I am making progress it's not a
failure there's no point in in assuming
that you're going to be able to fluently
speak a language after such a short
period of time there's a gestation
period where the brain gets used to the
language that's the one thing and the
other thing is I heartily recommend a
visit to Croatia and Bosnia I haven't
been to Montenegro and Serbia and I'm
sure that there are wonderful things to
be seen there as well and it is the same
language so I am attracted now to this
part of the world so I've discovered I
even bought some books about you know
because I unlink I've been going through
this the bridge over the Drina by Evo
under it which is very difficult for me
but I bought the book in serbo-croatian
in the Latin alphabet so that one day
maybe I'll be able to read that without
the help of a blink so there is no
failure there is no wasted effort
whatever we put into our language
learning it's all positive it's an
investment in future enjoyment on on
many levels so the next video will be
from Spain bye for now
[Music]